what's up Wolfgang today there's been
some confirmations of characters that
will appear in Avengers 4 but even more
interesting are the characters that are
rumored to be in Avengers 4 if you
haven't seen infinity war yet I'm sorry
there will be some spoilers in this
because if you haven't heard yet some
characters died in a vanity war and
unfortunately I will be talking about
some of those characters in this video
so I have to say it
spoiler alert before we get into the
video our speaker system giveaway is
still going all you have to do to enter
is subscribe to my channel subscribe to
the stupendous wave leave a like and
drop a comment with your favorite
superhero from Marvel DC or anything
else ok so there are a lot of characters
that are confirmed some are pretty
obvious but some aren't so obvious so
let's go ahead and start with the
characters that are really obvious so
obviously all the Avengers and heroes
that survived half the universe being
wiped out so all the Avengers that are
left alive so that's Iron Man Thor
Captain America war machine banner Black
Widow nebula and rocket then we have
some that were not as obvious but still
pretty obvious such as ant-man and the
wasp Hawkeye or Ronan sob in the next
movie and Captain Marvel then there's
one who is kind of surprising but at the
same time we could kind of see it before
and that is Loki kind of surprising
because he apparently died in infinity
war but he's the god of mischief so who
knows he could still be alive but
there's also the fact that leaked photos
of Avengers 4 showed Loki in New York
from the first Avengers movie so if they
go back in time and see him that's
different obviously than him being alive
so a little bit more surprising next is
Pepper Potts and happy they're both
alive this does come as a surprise
because we didn't have any idea if they
were alive or not but the one who
shocked me the most the absolute most
just blew my mind is Thanos that's right
Thanos will be in Avengers 4 who knew
wait
Oh moving on ok so now going on to the
characters that are rumored to be in
Avengers 4 and some of these are
surprising but again we'll start with
the least surprising and that is
Valkyrie Thanos only killed half of the
Asgardians on the ship we know this
because Thor says it so it's safe to
assume that Valkyrie led half of them
away because they showed each important
character on the ship when Thanos was
there such as Heimdall Dean and Loki and
I bet you cooked with him to Maine
next is Gamora it's only a rumor but it
can be pretty easy to add her to
Avengers 4 scene as Stannis has the soul
stone he already saw her once after he
eliminated half of the universe and it
seems like she's trapped in the soul
world so it would seem like he could
kind of see her whenever he wanted to or
she could possibly get revived by the
undoing of Thanos to snap if somebody
else gets the Infinity Gauntlet or if
they go back in time next is Hank Pym
this could be pretty easy to put him in
there especially if they need
time-travel it seems like Pym technology
would come into play maybe with the
combination of Tony's barf technology
next to spider-man again this could very
well come from the Avengers going back
in time or them undoing Thanos to snap
or they could even go with the route of
him being and Tony's thoughts all the
time like Tony could have post-traumatic
stress disorder and could just be
reliving the whole fight with fan oohs
over and over again and reliving the
moment where spider-man just started to
disintegrate then we have Quicksilver
this could happen in two ways I think
one is clearly time trouble they go back
in time we could see him back in time or
they in fact get the Infinity Gauntlet
and they can do whatever they want and
one that comes back and then she says
hey can you bring my brother back and
they do same thing with vision they
could easily bring everybody back with
Infinity Gauntlet and he's one of the
people that come back or they could go
back in time and again they could see
him there
or maybe sure he actually did perform
enough of the surgery that she was doing
on him for him to actually survive
without the mine stone one of the
rumored characters that actually really
was surprising is stature for those of
you who aren't familiar with whose
stature is she is Cassie Lane and yeah
that is Scott Lang or ant-man's daughter
this is somewhat of a surprise because
we can see in the ant-man of the wash
trailer that she's still a little girl
but maybe her and Hank Pym beam rumored
to be in this movie are in fact
confirmation to us that Avengers 4 will
be a time travel movie they'll just have
to travel forward in time to get her and
last but definitely not least is Harley
keiner if you don't remember who Harley
keiner is he is the little boy genius
who helped Tony Stark out in Iron Man 3
it seems like there's going to be an
older version of this character coming
into Avengers 4 this was confirmed by a
tweet from IMDB but nothing has been
confirmed from the studio yet so this
one is going to have to remain a rumor
and not confirmed yet so that's it for
all the characters that are confirmed
and rumored to be in Avengers 4 again
some are pretty obvious but some might
actually really like to see I wouldn't
mind to see stature and I'd actually
really like to see Harley keiner come in
and take over as Iron Man but if we're
really talking about what we'd like to
see I'd really love to see Adam warlock
show up and Galactus but these are ones
that we have here so what do you all
think about these and who do you wish
would show up in Avengers 4 let me know
in the comments below and if you enjoyed
the video please give it a thumbs up and
if you want to subscribe to my channel
and join the wolf gang I wouldn't hate
you for it thank you so much for
watching
woof woof
[Music]
[Music]